[Music]
hey guys it's me jasmine we are outside
today because we are gonna test some
tick-tock camping hacks we're gonna tell
you if they taste good and if they're
worth it or not but it wouldn't be
camping without some of my friends i
love camping
i love candy it's gonna be fun guys
we're just missing a pool where's the
cabana the pool in the forest it's all
about the dirt bring katie on your
camping trip let's go make some food
okay that's the idea yes
great great
[Music]
i'm up first and i found this one pan
mac and cheese recipe on tick tock i'm a
little skeptical about this recipe
because it calls for two different kinds
of milk and i feel like that's taking up
a lot of space in my cooler where a
margarita should be going so we'll have
to see if this recipe is worth it i'm
also a little nervous about the cook
time but let's see if it works so for my
version i'm gonna start with one pound
of elbow noodles and then i'm gonna add
two types of cheese i'm adding some
shredded monterey jack cheese for the
creaminess and then some sharp cheddar
just to add a little bit of that bite
next i'm gonna add some whole milk and
some heavy cream the key is to do both
it really adds to the richness and
creaminess some bacon bits because
everything's better with bacon i mean
come on season with little salt pepper
because katie likes pepper
then i'm add half a stick of melted
butter all right i'm just gonna stir
this up till everything is evenly
combined now i'm gonna cover it with
aluminum foil make sure it's sealed
tight and put it over my fire for about
one hour so i'm cooking over hot embers
and not direct flame so this has been
cooking for about 30 minutes as you can
see it's still super liquidy i did see
someone on tik tok bake this in the oven
before they went camping and then they
use the grill to reheat it so i think
i'm gonna go try that and then report
back this is out of the oven i'm gonna
put my finishing touches on it and see
how it tastes and for the extra punch
i'm gonna top my mac and cheese with
some flamin hot cheetos let's see if it
was worth it bringing all that milk
instead of the margaritas let's taste it
guys oh let me go in okay
whoa that's good yeah it's good what do
you think of the hot cheetos i really
like the hot cheetos on top it's a nice
crunch the bacon
mmm the only fail on this is that you
cooked it inside but it's not your fault
it was taking too long to cook it would
have wasted too much wood a little more
at home prep final thoughts is i think
it tastes really good but i don't know
if it's worth it to assemble it all put
it in your cooler and then have to
reheat it so final rating thumbs up up
middle guys are you guys ready for my
next one okay let's try the pizza do it
for my tick tock hack i have chosen a
really really simple one it really
involves only one ingredient frozen
pizza so if your friends last minute
were like you're in charge of lunch or
dinner you can run to the store pick up
a pizza and let it thaw in your car on
the way to the campsite the best part
about this is it's really really
customizable so i have let a pepperoni
pizza thaw and i'm gonna add just some
jalapenos they don't need to be
refrigerated it's easy to take with you
on the camping trip just place those all
around and then roll your pizza into a
spiral nice and tight oh my goodness
it's breaking i think we needed a more
doughier dough be honest with you that's
not great it's like an earthquake
happened to this pizza this is such a
fail we're still gonna eat this i'm just
gonna go bake it later
[Music]
[Laughter]
so we have a second pizza everyone we're
gonna try this again this was in the
refrigerated section so we're hoping
it's a bit more doughy adding jalapenos
slice them a little bit thinner this
time i don't know this doesn't feel
promising guys it's like a swiss roll
you might have some crack so it might be
okay okay okay some stuff fell out but
we've got a roll once we've got that log
we'll cut it into individual slices
bigger the better kelly says ready
and put these guys in a foil pouch
close up the pouch
ready to go on the fire we're gonna let
these guys cook for about 30 minutes or
until they're cooked all the way through
it's basically like a cinnamon roll but
with a pizza so we have our pizza off
the fire and it's time to see what it
looks like
oh a lot of steam coming out of here oh
it's definitely cooked through the
cheese is melted it doesn't look as
pretty as i was hoping and this is after
about 30 minutes
last thing we need to do is get jasmine
and kelly and see if they like it all
right pizza time yes it smells good it
smells good it doesn't like look amazing
but you're camping yeah so
i would have used um nonstick spray
non-stick spray all right let's go in oh
i got a jalapeno oh ready
mmm it's good it's good i mean it's
pizza mmm
but those jalapenos cooked
so the benefits of the roll is it kind
of feels like a sandwich or all of it's
all mushed together when you're camping
not everyone's hungry at the same time
so you can just take one roll throw it
on the fire it's more convenient totally
this is worth it how many thumbs up two
two thumbs up okay two thumbs up six
thumbs up six thumbs up
it's awesome i think it's your turn
oh it's dessert time baby we've done
savory now it's time for dessert
strawberry s'mores and i think camping's
not camping without s'mores although
easy it involves strawberries over a
fire which means warm strawberries and i
don't really know how i feel about it
but katie was pretty excited about it
it's gonna be good we'll see so super
simple you just take a strawberry put it
on a skewer and then take your
strawberry dip it in marshmallow cream
get it over the fire i like mine nice
and toasted just slightly burnt that
smokiness is amazing it's so hot jasmine
it's camping oh i also
goes like my knees i love your knees
those aren't long red socks those were
they like
i was wearing like stockings guys i went
on vacation i burned my leg
jasmine
i do have a question what why are you
wearing long sleeves because i don't
like the sun hitting my skin do you
smoke when you would trade spots yeah
yours is looking perfect in that
location though thank you let's go put
on toppings perfectly toaster
after you've toasted it to your liking
use your favorite toppings i am going
for a s'mores flavor because that's what
i'm craving so i am topping it with some
chocolate syrup
and of course graham cracker crumbs
whoa you know what i think leaving the
stems on is good because you can hold it
by the stem and not your hands as messy
i love the flavor i think kelly had a
really good idea earlier she mentioned
that if we used frozen strawberries they
might stay cold that is something that i
would be willing to try it was just too
warm for me i love the warm strawberry i
love the sweet chocolate i love this
sweet marshmallows with the char it was
a hundred percent up thumbs i'm a
jasmine on the warm fruit it's too warm
and it was so messy like
it's too gooey like i'd rather just eat
it in a traditional this had us more
it's messy that's way messier how many
up thumbs
i do one up thumb it's just not worth it
so i'm gonna say no and two up though
that's the rating system makes sense yes
yes but no
okay guys that's it we're done we're
super full thank you guys so much for
watching we're gonna go enjoy those
margaritas kelly was talking about let
us know in the comments if there are any
other tic tac hacks you want us to try
uh until then good bye
you guys are there everyone in the tank
margaritas
team margarita
oh yes
[Music]
[Music]
you